the way left looks at things is
sometimes we win and sometimes you lose
and that's the only way it's ever going
to happen and if it's ever different
than that
it's illegitimate
barack obama i think gave a in a way a
more appropriate
eulogy given the political tenor
of the funeral here's just a little clip
of barack obama's
stump speech eulogy but today
we witness with our own eyes police
officers kneeling on the necks
of black americans
george wallace may be gone
but we can witness
our federal government sending agents to
use tear gas and batons
against peaceful demonstrators but even
as we sit here
there are those in power who are doing
their darndest
to discourage people from voting
by closing polling locations and
targeting minorities
and students with restrictive id laws
and attacking our voting rights with
surgical precision
even undermining the postal service
in the run-up to an election
that's going to be dependent on mail-in
ballots so people don't get sick
those republicans are stealing your
votes they're stealing the election
they're no better than george wallace
they're segregationists they're racists
okay i hope you all have a lovely
funeral john lewis was a good guy
that is outrageous right
we all look at that
everyone from conservatives to
reasonable liberals
looks at that kind of eulogy and says
how outrageous
you've got a man there who's had a very
impressive political career
who's meant a lot to a lot of americans
and you're supposed to be celebrating
his life
and instead you turn it into a stump
speech right we don't like that
that's kind of we find that to be very
ugly however
the thing that is worth remembering here
is that
the left treats politics different than
the right does in a way
i think this political stump speech was
absolutely appropriate because
while the left wants to create an image
of john lewis is this man above
politics he's above the right and the
left he's above the political fray
that's not how john lewis viewed himself
john lewis was a 17-term
member of the house of representatives
he was openly one of the most ardent
liberals in the house if not the single
most ardent liberal
in the house he was referred to by the
washington post
as a fiercely partisan democrat so
i think it's perfectly understandable i
don't think it's it's disrespectful
of barack obama to john lewis's memory
to come out and give this political
speech
and and frankly that's how the left is
looking at that right now
the key to remember is the left
must win i hope you enjoyed that short
segment from the michael knowles show be
sure to check out the full episode
linked in the description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you